ed sheeran may have the voice of an  angel but he was slightly upstaged by a  young fan who had some killer dance  moves yeah during one of ed's recent  stadium shows a young boy  was living his absolute best life as he  was captured lighting up the dance floor  doing everything from the stanky leg to  the floss and even a little air guitar  amazing he was unstoppable it was yeah  just unstoppable out there and even ed's  team noticed on twitter sharing the  video alongside with the caption i think  it's the time ed gets a backup dancer  all right uh let's see those moves bye  everyone bye  bye take care  [Music]  [Music]  um  [Applause]  bye